In the light of the day, in the dark of the night, When you're raring to go, when you're tired from the fight, When you're losing your mind, let me give you a thought, I'm gonna be right by your side no matter what.
In the dark of the night, in the light of the day, When you're rising to shine, when you're hitting the hay, I'll be hanging around, if you like it or not, I'm gonna be right by your side no matter what.
No matter what.
In the dark of the night, in the light of the day, When you're rising to shine, when you're hitting the hay, Just remember this song.
How's it go?
I forgot!
I'm gonna be right by your side, no matter what.
Through whoever you've been, through whoever you'll be, Through whatever you lose, you will always have me.
At the end of your road, I'll be holding you tight.
I'm gonna be right by your side, no matter what.
Be right by your side, be right by your side, Be right by your side, no matter what.